[Music]
so they took maybe 20 bucks in an old
watch
mr matt sentiment did you even take a
swing
no could have taken her dad
heard you had some excitement last night
i wish they'd have picked my place you
know
why didn't you take them out i was just
trying to keep the damage to a minimum
yeah how's that working out for you
you okay cause you don't look okay
there's a long dormant piece of me
so very badly wants out
[Music]
what are you still doing here old man
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
[Music]
it's been a hell of a day you can see
that
for 12 years i work for some very
dangerous people
everybody gets to the basement what is
happening
don't call 9-1-1
i used to be what they call an auditor
the last guy anyone wants to see at
their door
because it meant you didn't have long to
live
but i left it behind to start a family
i might have uh over corrected
when you left you'd abandon a certain
debt that needs repayment
and your creditor is aware of your
[Music]
resurrection
i came after my family they stole my
kitty cat bracelet
you don't [ __ ] do that
[Music]
give me the goddamn kitty cat bracelet
he looks like [ __ ] dad you should see
the ellie guys
who the [ __ ] are you me
i'm nobody
[Music]
in theaters only february 26th
[Music]
you